you think about our great grandmothers
and our grandmothers they they didn't
care about the latest fashion trends
they didn't care about being all
polished and proper what was most
important to them was the men in their
lives true and this is what I tweeted
true femininity is actually women
serving men it has nothing to do with
clothes fashion or having your nails
done if you go get your nails done they
are serving you therefore it is not
feminine and my thought process was is
all of these girls that are really into
fashion typically live very selfish
lives and the things they do are
typically for them and therefore it
makes them unfeminine so J responded to
this and he said femininity doesn't
expand it enhances masculinity so then I